Yes, Shang, I'm good. How are you?
I'm good too. How's everything going on your end?
What can you find me?
Everything is good, all things up to your side.
Is drink.
Everything is going good. Everything is under control. So it's, I would say, monsoon has started. So got rid of the heat. How about you? How's the weather at there?
Pre.
Okay.
Perfectly fine. It was a little bit hot last week, but this week it's perfectly fine. Everything is good and in control. Hey Vishal.
Hey, very good morning or good afternoon, Nick. How's it doing?
Everything is good. How are you?
I'm doing good as well. Thank you.
Yeah.
I don't think will be joining because there is some escalation he's working on it. He's on client call, so yeah, we we can start, I think.
Akshay.
Okay, thanks. Let me share my screen. So, agenda says the same check in highlights, action tracker, KPI analysis, CSAT analysis, way forward, upcoming events and recap. So, Kumar is performing good. We have improved and
Um...
We have observed improvement trend in the Komal's performance for the last three months. And last month when we connected, there were some issues highlighted. One was like with onboarding requests, there were some issues coming up, but those issues at that moment seems reduced from the first month.
Then there were some issues with travel request. And the third thing was communication. These were the major issues that we could see with Kumar. Although apart from these, her performance was going good. So first, for onboarding request, I explained to her how she can improve on that.
so that she needs to follow the document and checklist. So she agreed and she said yes, although there haven't been any mistakes, but yes, I'll be more cautious. So for onboarding requests, do you see an improvement? Do you see any more challenges?
I think she is doing good. I don't have any escalation for onboarding or onboarding, although I'm not giving the onboarding or onboarding for major clients like Ben, because they specifically asked. OK, so we are not giving just because to gain some confidence that if she is doing good with other clients, then we will start getting them, so there is no escalation for onboarding or onboarding.
Okay.
Good enough.
For travel requests, yes, there is a couple of myths, or that what I did, like I asked her to not close the ticket, just do the travel request things, and then somebody from my team, like the Kushang or Ashish is senior enough, they will be doing a ticket, sorry, peer review 15 minutes a day, and just give her a feedback that this thing has to be done and this thing.
It's good. I think couple of weeks I'll be doing that and after that she'll be good in travel request as well.
So with travel request specifically, I spoke with her and I asked her, like, what's the challenge? She was first hesitant and then she said, okay, I'm not very clear with the process. I said, understood. So you need to talk to Iqbal, ask for his feedback.
Tell him that I do not know. Do one thing, go back to Iqbal. Understand the complete process once again. If there is any confusion, ask again. Till the time you are 100% confident that you have understood. Please keep asking and do not let...
Iqbal know or do not let Iqbal understand that you are 100% confident. So until unless you are confident, do not let Iqbal know that I am 100% confident. So apart from this, have you seen any escalation coming up in travel requests in the last one month since we connected?
It.
Yeah, this is one from WBC, but I understand that travel request, you know, you're not completely dependent on the process. It's the client-to-client environment, you know, which varies. So that is why I'm not blaming Komal to have these mistakes. That is why I set up this peer review, because these guys are pretty old with these clients, so they know these environments better.
Or an issue.
Yes.
Once she will be doing tickets for these clients, she will be handy as well. So I'll not say escalation, yeah, there was some, what should you say, configuration gap which happened for one client, WPC, they came to me that this guy is not working. But anyhow, I'll take care of that. I'll not say that that is escalation, I'll take care of it early.
Correct.
Okay, apart from that, we saw that there were a lot of misses happening on the travel request for other clients. So I would like to know like just one issue came up in travel request for all the tickets that she handled or there were other issues that happened as well or something which was caught in peer review or something like that.
So this is something which has been captured because client has directly called me that this is not working. So there are a couple of things which is, you know, being handled by teams directly, like, you know, if she handles her travel request and that particular user is calling directly as that, see, this is not working, those things don't come.
To me, so tickets have been done by these technicians, so one escalation directly came to me, and I would say that.
That is not the miss from side, that is something you know, from configuration point of view. There is what I said, like, let me do this peer review kind of stuff for a couple of weeks, and I'll give you feedback, but honestly, onboarding, overboarding, she is good. I'm sure that is something she she will cover as well.
Okay, the next thing that Venkat said, like she was clearly reaching out to the new joiners who were basically college grads. She was going to them asking them for help. So I made her understand and I asked her to utilize the Teams chat, group chat. So.
That was one area where she had asked. She said, okay, I understand now. I'll go forward with this only. And I explained what Venkat had said, like she could have reached out to Venkat asking for an approval rather than sending an e-mail from ConnectWise Management. So yes, all of those things we gave her feedback. We made her understand where she was missing.
Kip.
She understood it, she took it positively. I guess those gaps are, I would not say zero, but those gaps are eliminating now. Do you see better performance from her?
Yeah, last one week I think she was off, so I cannot recall that she has posted anything in group, but anyhow, like she has started posting in groups rather than sending in Brazil, you know, the things. But as I said that last one week, she was not there. So let me leave you this week.
Yes.
I'll pass and feed it to you, but I'll I'll monitor it like that's what I can see.
Okay.
Shashank, when do we have next service call scheduled?
Okay, yeah.
Next service call would be scheduled around.
In August, that would be 5th or 12th, I guess 12th.
I mean, it in August, right? OK, yeah.
Yes, I was just wondering if we can have a quick follow-up call, equal maybe next week as per your convenience, to just see how was the progress weekly wise for Kumar. You know, because sometimes you're just connecting once in a month, then you know, sometimes you know, we can we can, you know, allow a few things to.
Partner.
slip between the chairs. So just want to check, you know, because it is critical for us to know that how she's improving and if anything else we can do from our side equal. I, what I understand, travel requests are critical, so it is important that, you know, she should have absolutely crystal clear clarity on process. So weekly connect.
at least for some time. Again, that is just a suggestion based on your availability. Maybe Venkat will continue to be available on monthly service call only, but we can have a quick follow up call with you, how she's doing.
I.
I wonder.
Sure, sure. No, no worries. Like, we can have a bi-weekly call. We can connect after two weeks for this. If you're OK with that, we can, we can do, we can do 15, 20 minutes call just for the feedback like this. We can do.
Yes.
Yeah, absolutely, at least for the next three to four weeks, so that we know, we know, because this is a self-managed environment and we don't have, or we have a very limited or no access at all on these requests, so we just depend, you know, we have the dependency on you when you're letting us know how she's doing, and sometimes we just hear back from, you know, engineer only how they're doing, how they're performing, right?
And you understand, engineers, they always feel that they're doing 100% correct. They don't have any escalation over there, right? So that is, I think a quick call with you will definitely help. So I'll let Shashank reach out to you to schedule a weekly connect. And I really appreciate your support on this, Iqua. Thank you so much.
Yeah, I know.
Hello.
Not sure.
Shorts, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Yep.
I'll connect via Teams so we can directly ping and I'll ask Iqbal if there's anything concerning, then I'll set up a call. Otherwise, I'll just ask him ping by Friday, if they, this Friday if.
Let's set up a call. Let's set up a call. Communication is always great over calls, rather than just Teams. And I'm sure 15 minutes call, it could be a quick 5 minutes call, but it will give us more clarity and keep everybody on the same page, Shashank.
Sure.
Yeah.
I agree, thank you.
I'll try and schedule something for Friday so that by Friday we would have the entire week. Okay, any feedback or suggestions which you want to give Ibar?
Thank you.
For Kumar.
Shoot.
Good, since last commit.
Oh, great, great.
And last, last, last questions. Sorry, I come with lots of questions over there. If I have to ask you to rate her right now out of 10, how do you rate herself?
No worries.
Please.
So if I'll compare Komal with my other tier ones, like one I hired like just a couple of months back, and the co-ops, I may not rate her higher because I'm not giving her complex tickets because I don't have that confidence yet. But if I rate her the work she's doing, I'll give 7 to 8 because since last connect, she has approved.
Mhm.
Okay.
But I am not utilizing her properly, not properly, completely, I would say, because you know, there is something back in mind, like if I'll give this thing to her, I may get escalations. For this, I just want to slowly give her the complex tickets one by one. Last week she was on leave, before that she was doing good. Today as well, I have given some different tickets to her.
So I think couple of weeks I'll take to understand if she's totally good in the environment, I'll give her more complexity. Then I'll actually read her with the, you know, comparing other team members.
No, it does it does make sense and it gives me the clarity as well, where there is a scope of improvement for herself and where me or Shashank can talk to her, so that is that is the only reason you know I ask these questions.
It is, it is.
It is, it is a scope of improvement for her as well, but you know, at the same time, we have to be confident that she will fix the issue. Sometimes you are giving a ticket from some major client to some technicians and they are not doing that good because we cannot monitor, you know, one-to-one if she is not sitting here.
She's a remote resource. So if we have given tickets, she has to work there only. So that is what I'm saying. Like once you have a confidence in a technician, you can pass on any tickets if that's a remote resource.
Yep, I understand. I understand.
Yes, and that is what that is where we really want to, you know, reach that level where you have that 100% trust, because if you ask me, I really want her to be there in your top three, if not top five, over there, you know, for you. That is that is what I want to hear from you. So, I just want to ensure that we are doing everything from our side, whatsoever is possibly in our limited support.
Yeah.
We, we, we are, you know, one thing what I noticed from we need to work on her confidence as well. Maybe she is aware of process, but she's not really confident to execute those steps, so that is 1 feedback that I'm taking taking out of this call that we just need to talk to talk talk to her when we are having a conversation, Shashank. That will be one thing, and...
Thank you.
Do you have a weekly or a monthly call set up with her equal? I mean, general feedback that you're doing?
We are, we are doing ticket reviews, so it is not basically one-to-one call in a week or two. We used to do, I used to do a ticket review with her, where I used to pass on the feedbacks of escalations and the queue she have. That is something that generally do with every technicians, but there is not a permanent call that weekly or bi-weekly that it depends on the workload and the escalations of.
Mhm.
any feedback from client. So weekly or bi-weekly, we used to connect with every technician, similarly with Komal, to just give an overview of her queue, her performance and everything.
Okay.
OK, so initially I think her her role was to take calls or more on taking client calls rather than doing the the the tech side work over there. If I I could be I could be wrong, but...
So, my expectation, my expectation from her is taking calls, like call is everybody is taking call, but you know, somebody sitting in office maybe doing some other stuff, so she's number one taking calls, second onboarding, offboarding, third the these travel requests, and 4th the interrelated issue only.
Mhm.
Resetting password, resetting password, or making groups, or making this. That is the expectation from Komal, and that is what I discussed with Venkat only. I am not expecting her to be tier 2 or bring a complex ticket, so I am just trying to reach there only. Right now, I am giving her onboarding, offboarding, and travel request only, and even interrelated issues are not giving her much.
OK, got it.
Drew.
Makes sense.
And, but for onboarding, offboarding, I'm not giving them, I'm not giving cross-link, I'm not giving WPC because those clients are not comfortable, especially because you have escalation. So I just want to reach there where I am fully confident to give all the onboarding, offboarding to Komal, travel request to Komal, and the
Be it even like this password reset and this group, where like this kind of issue, if I am fully confident to give it, that that is something I can give a 10 to 10 to Kumar.
No, thank you for the clarity. Again, that sounds like a plan and that gives us clarity as well. So Shashank, Shashank, whenever we are having a conversation with Kumar, we just need to address them in this way. And I think that is where these weekly calls are going to be very handy. So again, thank you so much. Yeah.
I hope.
Sure.
No, no, no, I'll clearly ask her that if you're getting, if she's getting a call with, you know, there's some issue which she don't understand from environment point of view, just create a ticket and pass on to me. I'll take care of that. I understand that.
And that is, that is expectation from.
Perfect, makes sense.
No, it does make sense. But thank you. Thank you for all the clarity around it. And thank you for bearing with me patiently.
And one good thing, one good, one good thing, last week she, like our social engineering team used to call the technicians to trap technician by saying, hey, I'm this and that, reset my password. And they're very rude by saying, so the technician will come into pressure and reset the password. But she didn't come into pressure, she followed the process properly.
And she messaged the primary. Even primary got confused that that person is sitting in front of me why somebody is asking to reset his password. And she got negative for that. Client gave her negative. I spoke to client, I explained that this was a trap or this was a, you know, social media test which she passed, basically.
And client said that client was happy and then I spoke to my director and I wave of that negative to positive to five star.
Ohh, great.
Okay, no, thank you. Thank you for explaining that. She definitely deserves some GPS points, Shashank, on this one. Yeah, thank you.
Prince.
Yeah.
Yeah, and honestly, I was discussing that with her earlier as well, yesterday, because she came back after a week holiday. So that's what I discussed with her. Moving on next to action tracker, no to lose from previous meeting, performance analysis.
Play.
Sorry, Shashank, back to you, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes, utilization is going good. It's meeting the required targets.
Yep.
Ticket count, ticket closure is set it to 220. Is that an average ticket closure while on your end or it's somewhat less on your end for every technician like 160 or 180 in a month? Something like that. Is there anything?
Two 20 from where you got this number, total ticket part technician.
Initially, initially when we started our partnership with F12, it was an expectation set like 220 is a general thing. So that's why I keep 220 but yes, with every IST.
No, I think that.
It depends on the number of volume. So right now I have 90 tickets on board. I cannot expect 200 tickets to be closed in a day. So I'll let you know the expectation. No, there's only thing. I'll let you. I understand. I'll let you know the expectation from her. Right now I don't have that number handy. I'll let you know because in our IST right now.
No, it's for the man.
It is for the.
Ticket volume is not that high, but we are going to acquire a new client, PPJV, which is almost equal to the current ticket volume. So it will be doubled right now, like in coming months. So right now, if I will say daily ticket open rate is 90, but sorry, it will be 180 or 190 by next month. So.
So, we are expecting to complete, we are we are expecting to complete that acquisition, uh, in in July itself, it will.
That number will change.
Yes, that client has already onboarded with us, but you know, the partially tickets we are getting, it is under project. So first, project will take care of that client and then they will hand over to us. So hopefully end of July or August, mid of August, we will get that client. And then the ticket volume will be high and this benchmark will be different.
Great.
Perfect.
So, I will let you know that the number.
For that.
Sure, no worries.
Okay, CSAT, CSAT, 100%, we can see that there is a good growth. Last one she got around 10 surveys, 10, 11 surveys, this one, 14 surveys. So survey count has definitely improved. There was one ticket on which we saw good positive comments, like quick response, pleasant, helpful attitude, and
Okay.
positive resolution. So this was one of the good comments that she received. So that was going good. Moving on next, this is the attendance data for her. There was one unplanned leave in the month of June, 22nd June, where she felt sick.
Yep.
That's it, nothing major apart from this, just a way forward, like we continue working with Komal on improving her matrix and making her more consistent towards work so that we see the confidence of the clients growing back in her. So that's one thing that our focus area is.
And definitely we'll set up a weekly.
Connect with you, Iqbal, from next week so that we can just go ahead and see how the things progressing for her.
Nope.
Thank you.
Okay.
Show shop in the Kip.
Anything you would like to add, Iqbal?
No, I think we discussed most of things. Everything is good. As you said that we also are working with Kumar to make, you know, make sure that he's good with the expectation we have. So I will also be working with him. No worries. Nothing, nothing special for him.
Prince.
Okay, great. Vishal, anything you would like to add?
No, no, I think it was really, really great to connect with you, Vishal. And thank you for, thank you for your patience and to bear with my most of my questions. I just want to ensure that, you know,
Okay.
because we have a limited access to this environment, thanks to this, you know, the model that we follow. So yes, I appreciate all the clarity. Even, you know, when we are giving the feedback to the engineers, right? Although you are directly managing them, and this is more on you, you know, if you see a gap over there.
Mhm.
Kip.
But I have given, you know, a suggestion to, you know, when I'm working with our ISTs and for a few of them it has worked really well, that you know, maybe once in a month or maybe once in two months, whenever you're talking to your engineers, in case if you want Shashank to be there, so you know, everybody on the same page, so sometime it really works well, gives a...
Mhm.
positive things to everyone that you know. Shashank will have absolutely clarity that what exactly you know you're expecting from Komal and even Komal, if she has any concerns, she can always reach out to Shashank as well. Just to enhance the team collaboration where we can do better. Just a suggestion if we can.
Okay.
Sandhu.
In case, if you need, if you, if you want that, we can follow this model as well, once, or you know, in one month or two months, again.
No worries. I actually, I spoke to Shashank last week, last connect as well. I don't want to be into that model and we're complaining about tech. So if I am asking, like this is what my assumption that if I'm asking Shashank to come into that connect, Google might think that there is something wrong and I'm asking Shashank to come.
So I'm okay with, like, I'm okay with Komal. I'll have a review and I'm sure that she will do good. As you said, that bi-weekly connects, we'll connect bi-weekly for a couple of weeks and then see if there's some progress and I'm good. I think that there's no issue in that.
Yep, absolutely.
No, perfect. That works for me. Thank you so much for your time. At least I'm good. Thank you so much, Shashank.
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thanks, Iqbal. Thanks, Vishal. Have a great day.
Okay, right.
Thank you, Gwen.
Sprite.